for two long years we've lived with
covid restrictions
today a new dawn
the government calling time on the rules
that have shaped all our lives is it too
soon to relax restrictions
the very life question and the cabinet
with its answer today all restrictions
will be gone by thursday is the
government being too hasty
his cabinet now agreed the pm to
parliament
together with the treatments and
scientific understanding of the virus
that we've built up we now have
sufficient levels of immunity to
complete the transition from protecting
people with government interventions
to relying on vaccines and treatments as
our first line of defense
self-isolation rules acts the end of
free universal testing and a fourth jab
for the vulnerable all bold moves
and the opposition not convinced the
prime minister promised to present a
plan for living with covid
but all we've got today is yet more
chaos and disarray
free tests can't continue forever but if
you're 2-1 up with 10 minutes to go you
don't sub off one of your best defenders
but for those on his own side announcing
the end to restrictions is the best
political defense for this embattled pm
i'll take the prime minister's statement
if i may as his application to join the
covered recovery group he's very welcome
indeed i only wish it had been uh sooner
i strongly welcome and endorse my
writing reference statement today
restoring our freedoms
a return to freedom perhaps but it's not
without cost the scientist is clear the
virus is still with us
as we look at the next weeks we still
have high rates of omicron
and i would urge people in terms of
public health advice that people should
still if they have covered
uh try to prevent other people getting
it and that means self-isolating very
clear this pandemic is not over as um
an american colleague put it at the
weekend he said you can celebrate when
the sun's shining but take your umbrella
with you it seems to me that you're
clear you're making it clear that this
pandemic is far from over what are you
feeling are you more anxious
than confident as these restrictions are
dropped
on the anxiety point
i i don't want you to think that there's
some
you know uh
division between uh the the the gung-ho
politicians and the and the cautious
anxious scientists this has not gone
away there could be likely will be
another variant
that will cause us trouble
but
i believe that thanks to a lot of the
stuff that we've done we'll be in a far
better position to tackle uh that new
variant when it comes the one thing that
this virus has taught you is not to be
cocky yeah so i think we just need to go
very carefully we need to monitor
carefully and be prepared to react
those covered news conferences have
punctuated have not dominated all of our
lives for the past couple
of years so it was a very significant
moment today when the prime minister
flanked by his advisors finally press
pause
but their confidence and hope that this
phase of kovid is now coming to an end
was tempered too with a heavy dose of
caution around potential new variants
and tricky winters restrictions over for
now but perhaps not
forever tonight turn in the page then on
a pandemic that's defined this prime
minister's premiership and could still
decide his legacy too
beth rigby sky news westminster